hello and welcome to this video playing
easy max maybe that's the way to
pronounce it
mm Oh waiting for this is actually
somewhat interesting and I see are you
taking place you six
yeah it's Kiwanis way of doing it Bishop
g7 okay six
to go a 600 a 697 something no a 696
Bishop d7 as how he plays it a 696 okay
Bishop everyone is not really super
dangerous discovered check but let's
avoid it
yeah this is not exactly a way for wine
to refute the petrol no it's not the
most exciting position ever but if you
want a position where you don't get
checkmated in twenty-something moves and
where you feel you can outplay the
opponent may be in an ending that's your
kind of game okay and so it doesn't
really have won't ha ha that's it's all
a little bit what is that doing you're
thinking which is go rupee one
yeah but I can probably not do all that
much about it right I was wondering
about the bishop like if I can go bishop
age six this is a bit awkward mmm it's
probably difficult to do to get down
again III or h4 h4 I wanted to go Knight
h5 intending g5
so probably Bishop e3 looks more to the
point after which they don't have
anything great I mean but do we it that
it takes so long for this decision what
is that to think about really I mean you
can argue Bishop f4 but I don't know
that can hardly be better than but
should be three mmm I don't know or is
he actually trying to tempt me into this
95 but I have g5 against it
95g 597 Roxy 8 wins material and if you
just give me the bishop pair here for
absolutely nothing
I have a little bit I can play this
position with some reasoning behind it
okay just for I guess yeah this is solid
you still solid for white to be six
the bishop on g3 looks quite stupid him
it's difficult still to do anything with
this Hecht maybe this and f5 okay
yeah something's happening here it's not
entirely it's not like nothing is going
on here it's just my waiter came so he's
arguing mmm okay if a player five takes
rook takes this Knight each form and the
Bishop d5 at the end that is very very
true
okay that means that f5 is a is not a
good idea at all
I can't prepare it in some way this one
it's probably still not good at five
[Music]
still not a good move interesting
he wants to go f4 here it seems
yeah I didn't play that well ah
London the frigging pawn Minch that is
so unnecessary really I mean I didn't
have anything but I also didn't have any
problem losing that game would be a real
shame because I mean why did absolutely
zilch
and if anything he was worse but nothing
special of course okay okay
shouldn't be too ambitious yeah really
it looks like white has a hard time to
convert this pawn I'd have to be
cautious that I'm not getting ambitious
I tend to do that I feel they play in a
way that it really is no less the win
possible for them I tried to win myself
and that is oftentimes just complete
insanity still I mean how bad candy five
beam
it can be bad I'm such an idiot
I had a draw in hand and then you I knew
that as I mentioned I tend to be too
ambitious if I feel they play badly and
have no winning chance and I tried to
kill myself
still okay
hmm okay I don't really want that
straight it's nothing to do
okay so let's push this one
and was really close to lose on time
okay there was a weird game i just
blunder be seven in one move what a
stupid way to play I mean just F takes
and it's not nothing much happens I
think mmm yeah that is really alone
that's not good really but it's so so
difficult to get somewhere yeah the
engine is pointing out the improvement
and five is of course is the right plan
but I should do this and then at five
then is a lot better this should be too
was good of course now I cannot play a
five threading it can take and you want
to take with this and then night h4 I'm
actually surprised that this is so
supposed to be okay for me but I you
know I'd never looked at this move which
which is possible at least I mean it's
not what you want to do it at least
you're not losing him but a lot stronger
is the 97 plan and now things are okay
for white I think it was rather better
than anything else I was panicking a
little bit with the time to came down
but I think if I took with the point I
should so be fine it's not good
it's not good yeah he's got a good
Bishop pal and it's not like my pieces
are well coordinated I thought I could
maybe blunt one Bishop here it's it's
not then white is better here
I miss play at the forum like here I was
really panicking a little bit and now he
just wins or should win but he played
some weird weird things I think I'm
starting to be okay here maybe he still
has aged for so I mean the pawn is not
felt but he's got aged for took him a
while to prepare that but I should
probably not go d5 and just just yeah
sit still but I mean the way it turned
out I actually had some chances
yeah I'm objectively lost but I wonder
they've had some chances later I'm okay
I probably did a draw the whole time
like even here it's probably a draw
cannot do much him yeah layer him I was
okay for the most part after the opening
but then I got into trouble 97 that that
said something that's interesting I
think that I should play 97 in this
position
and the computer wants to coach if five
years also interesting now night is
seven and then nine age 5 and then a 5
ok I mean it's it was Bishop h4 is a
fairly clear strategic mistake because
the bishop is bad down on g3 it looks at
those pawns it makes no sense
you should just play Bishop e3 here in
97 year they're taking is considered to
be best by the engine but that is it's
funny you go hip like this is better
like forever with the bishop and and I'm
getting rid of this Knight easily am but
the knight move and c6 and then I'm
pushing pawns forward ok thanks a lot
for watching